all right siege heads year six season
one
is upon us and since ubisoft were
awesome enough to let us check it out
early
we're here to talk about it now it isn't
a huge update but the changes it does
bring
are life-changing we've got streamer
mode
match replays a border rework picks
after the prep phase
and remote controlled nitro cells
let's [ __ ] go
okay so before we start talking shop i
thought i would just remind you all that
we are with an earshot
of two million subs and that it's a
milestone that i'd like to hit
sometime in the near future like before
valk inevitably gets acog
kappa also make sure to like subscribe
and let us know in the comments if you
want to see more in the weeds siege
content such as this
this past wednesday ubisoft let us
participate in the preview event for
year six's inaugural season
crimson heist not operation crimson
heist
they dropped that part probably because
cs go operations exist
even though they suck i was also afford
the privilege of sitting down with one
of siege's most recognizable and
widely adored game designers emilie
lomet
who was kind enough to answer all of my
burning questions about this newest
update
okay so it's called crimson heist
because the new operator is a swanky
sneaky thiefy argentinian boy named
flores
he boasts thatcher's ar-33 which is
woefully underrated i might add and his
gadget is a drone that becomes
bulletproof
and explodes upon detonation
now for those who don't know siege has
been suffering from a
surplus of defender utility for quite
some time
this gave way to the so-called 20-second
meta where attackers would spend the
first
two minutes of the round removing gadget
after gadget
before executing with you guessed it 20
seconds to go
now during the neon dawn reveal emilian
told me that ubisoft were out to change
that but that it would be a nearly
year-long process flores it seems is the
headliner of step
two of that process the philosophy is
twofold as you mentioned that is
uh it was like it's in the nine-month
process so nine months ago
part of twenty second meta we need
answers to that
we know that you cannot insert luck with
that problem with an operator a single
one because if you release the one or
parallel that's supposed to address the
meta how well it becomes either a must
pick or fail to do what you're supposed
to do
so the key of addressing the 22nd meta
came with a lot of changes that we
discussed last season university
for season four uh the golden six for
season one
uh malusi goyo so those are the key
aspects of the 20-second method but
having this program to solve is also an
opportunity
for us to make an operator that ties in
to this direction and flores is exactly
that
now if you know anything about siege you
can probably easily imagine that a
remote controlled ash
zofia charge meets nitro cell is a very
effective way of removing that utility
you can also kill people with it which
hey
we take those i should also mention that
flores gets
four of these little rugrats which
considering you can straight up murder
dudes with them
is a lot what we wanted though is have a
gameplay between attack and defense we
want the attacker to collect information
on the location of devices
then play the plan the path in their
head and then destroy it
but we also want the thunder to play
around that and know that those threats
are coming in and that they can deal
with it
and that's why we went for four right
like those two
three usually are for gadget that are
going to do their job no matter what
unless there is this specific contour
against it
here we're more in a gray zone like
defender can absolutely
destroy all four of them before they can
do anything so that's why we went all
the way up to four
it's because we wanted this gameplay and
that's also why
they have been designed to be big and
noisy now at first i caught myself
saying
that's essentially four lethal guided
zofia charges
that might be a little overtuned but
then i realized
so what wouldn't it be nice to have an
attacker feel overpowered for a change
especially given how long the game has
felt defender sided don't get me wrong
i'm not advocating for the second coming
of lion or anything like that what i am
saying
is that it wouldn't hurt to throw the
attackers a bone once in a while
you look at the likes of goyo and melusi
and think
why not give the attack something is fun
and destructive
obviously it's too early to say whether
it'll end up being overpowered or not
and trust me i'm not one of those people
who freaks out
every season about how imbalanced the
new operator is going to be
but for the first time in a long time i
looked at the new operator and thought
damn this could be kind of nutty and
that's probably a good thing i hope
they're not going to be
is not going to be too strong because
that's not that's not the intention we
have other ways to shift the meta
between attack and defense
rather than single operator however i
really hope it's going to be good as you
said as in
useful interesting and more importantly
fun what's even crazier though is that
they added a
secondary weapon i repeat weapon
that essentially turns a select number
of attackers
into zofia it's a one-off grenade
launcher with the same soft breech
concussive and
gadget removal capabilities as sophia's
ks79 lifeline so in the same sense that
we introduced the secondary heart breach
we're introducing secondary weapon
going six to be uh this alternative to
russian sofia
to not have ash tokya every every round
everyone and
i'm not saying we should never pick up
suzuki that really cool character really
fun to play
but the reliance on them having to have
them everyone
i hope is no longer going to be the case
taken together these could actually have
a very large influence on attackers
ability to
play the goddamn video game again
ubisoft promised radical changes in the
wake of neon dawn and
it is starting to look as if soon enough
siege will no longer be a utility
removal simulator
and while it is too early to start
making these kinds of sweeping
declarations
i gotta say attack is starting to look
pretty strong
this is helped by the fact that courtesy
of crimson heist
attackers can now re-pick their
operators
after the prep phase yes you heard me
after the prep phase this means you can
scope out where the defenders are
what their setup is and where a certain
useless spawn peaking jaeger is making
his way before you even decide on which
operator to pick never mind which guns
attachments and gadgets you're going to
run
we pick a attack on preface i have so
many people that tells you yes but now
as a defender
what what point do i have to like uh
place a weir frost or stuff like that
they're going to be able to adapt well
okay but now when you do that
you don't really care what the attacking
team is doing they can't change anything
you don't care to drone you you can be
vigilant they can see you it doesn't
matter
but right now your preface the defender
already very interesting moment becomes
a lot more relevant you have to protect
yourself from drone
deny information conceal stuff you have
much more of a gameplay with the
attacking team
needless to say this should do wonders
for lowering the pick rate of
do-it-all panacea operators like
thatcher hibana and zofia
and increase the pick rate of those nice
situational operators who
usually don't get picked on the off
chance that they don't work out
and the best thing of all of this is
that instead of going into
every round with this jack-of-all-trade
lineup with thatcher thermite
and ash and zofia because you want to be
able to do everything well now you don't
have to do everything you have to do
this specific task and with this
it opens a lot of slots a lot of
interesting opportunity
to bring off meta and and
situational picks that are going to be
relevant and tailored to the situation
you've collected information on
next up we've got the border rework look
as someone who actually hasn't been the
biggest fan
of how transformative the recent map
reworks have been
i gotta say i love love
this rework why because they barely
touched the map
it's not the the map became bad it's
that the game evolved the players
evolved the strat of all the the way we
play siege all together
is no different and that was exactly the
philosophy
for our level designer behind it like
keep the good stuff
and just tweak the the stuff that were
not completely working right
they massaged the parts that needed
massaging in this case opening up
showers and creating a connector between
securities and top east stairs
and leaving virtually everything else
intact i really
really hope they adopt this same
approach for future reworks
like bank speaking of map reworks
ubisoft revealed that as part of their
2021 road map
they'd be taking a second crack at
favela
and thank the [ __ ] lord outback
they also announced some really exciting
stuff in terms of operator reworks
for starters they're making it so that
melusi's mines are going to be a
shitload easier to destroy
they're also removing the shield portion
of goyo's deployables leaving just this
kind of shrouded explosive
making his area denial a lot less
oppressive ubisoft also teased that
later in the year we'd be seeing reworks
of
mira maestro finca and fuse
now i don't know about you but i am
madly excited about these reworks
a future in which my boy fuse is viable
is the future i want my children to grow
up in
but of all the things that crimson heist
has bestowed upon we the students of
siege
none are as holy as hallowed as the fact
that we can finally watch a [ __ ]
replay that's right siege's match replay
system is
finally entering beta i cannot overstate
how
life-changing this is going to be for
coaches analysts and
content creators look you can't have a
tier one esport
without a replay infrastructure and
finally siege is no longer going to be
the outlier in that respect
oh and by the way we're finally getting
the cali elite that was leaked ages ago
you know the one that turns her into a
widowmaker cosplayer
like bro just look at the way she holds
her rifle am i the only one who sees
this
in fact the only change that crimson
heist brought that didn't immediately
jump out to me is fantastic
is the fact that players can now control
drones and
certain gadgets after death
now ubisoft's motivation for making this
change is totally understandable they
want to lessen the amount of time
in between action phases and keep
players involved and engaged at
every stage of the round the issue is
that i really don't want maestro or echo
to be able to mess with me
after i've already killed them because
then well
what was the point of killing them as
for how all of this actually pans out
or if ubisoft actually decides to revert
some of it down the road
remains to be seen uh this is the future
we're very confident in
and we know that the impact on all the
operator we have is going to vary based
on whether the attacker or defender
whether what gadget they have
and we will have to if we're doing the
big heavy lifting right now and then
we're going to have to do the fine
tuning to get exactly where we're
supposed to be
for all of those operators anyway all in
all an absolute
banger of a season reveal not a ton of
changes but the ones they did implement
have the potential to be huge i know it
feels like i've been saying for a while
now that the future of siege is finally
looking bright
but to me at least it's starting to feel
true
nice
bruh wow
yeah the colton factor is huge can't
downplay that
oh my god